ashfield in europe has helped european ue
one of asf he uses it and european ue
on
in spite of mobility passive of discord
what what has teplice twice fioutch
and hexa chicks backbones francs room
it's a fright all afrikaans anthony
blanc has everything for antibes date is not
your eyes distinguished by twin twisters
soft [ __ ] dominating willy jean louis do
believe with our humanist philosophy
as i would have refused not to
deal with the greek case would have been an
unforgivable weakness an error
repeatedly repeated
if the commission had not done what it did in
business says yes absolutely
the security and borders to a wrestler
and is to be trend all very clearly
a nice score and the accumulation
footnote signs and he did you know how
to be done by this world as a binding
global climate deal we have also
carried out during the past year
a number of reforms
in my eyes substantial so old
european let's not give up
let's continue